Film Courage: When you sit down to write a
story do you begin with an outlining?
Van Ditthavong, Filmmaker/Photographer: Every
single script has been different.
The last one I just did ALL ROADS TO PEARLA
I did outline.
The last one I just did is called ONLY THE
DEAD LEAVE EARLY I did not outline at all.
I just started with an image and then locked
myself up, locked myself in a car.
I would drive my wife to work and then I would
sit in the car because that would force me
not to look at my phone and I would write
for a couple of hours.
Then that way I could talk things out.
So if you’re walking by and seeing this
guy talking to himself in a car he’s either
gone crazy or something but I felt that was
right for that particular script and that
made me do it every day something that made
me do it.
Another script prior to was a different process
so it just changes.
I think that might be international because
I want to try different ways but what kind
of helped me was maybe hearing Jeff Nichols
talk about movie days and that gave me a structure
like Movie Day 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 if the
movie took place in seven days that gave me
a feel of what is going to happen during that
time with these characters.
I think it depends for each one but I think
the outline does help.
Sometimes I know the ending prior to so I
will work backwards and if I ever get stuck
I will jump different places and jump different
scenes.
I usually have an image to start out with
and then something to end with and I’ll
build and then eliminate and form up the story
there but I try to lead with the characters
and once I have a solid grip and understanding
the characters sort of let them go in the
story.
Film Courage: What was the image for ALL ROADS
TO PEARLA?
Van: Wow…you know at first it was…a plastic
bag hanging in a tree and near a nodding donkey
just going back and forth and the sound of
the chain (tick, tick, tick) and then it was
just the landscape and I remember I did a
mood reel six years ago showing what type
of film I would want (I would cut that piece
together) and I put that piece with Daniel
Johnson’s song Deviltown.
It’s funny to see that mood reel six years
ago and then the trailer now how close it
is.
It’s kind of cool that the world still maintained
throughout through the process so I like that.
But the image was this plastic bag that just
was stuck in a tree.
Question For The Viewers: Do you think of
“movie days” when you are writing?